just a spoonful of sugar and MARY
POPPINS can make the medicine go down
she's back MARY POPPINS is back on our
screens once again only this time it's a
little bit different so different in
fact that the new movie might really
shock Millennials who've grown up with
the old Mary Poppins now let's check out
the major differences between the old
and the new Mary Poppins movie laughing
so much you fly one of perhaps the most
magical things to ever see in the
original Mary Poppins is the visit to
the oddball uncle laughing so much he
actually flies all the way to the
ceiling it's an absolutely hilarious
scene that made us all laugh a bit more
in order to see if we could fly to uncle
Albert's just love to laugh Wow long and
clear and it was getting worse every
year unfortunately kids today won't get
to experience that because Uncle Albert
has been replaced by a wacky cousin
Topsy sure it doesn't hurt that cousin
Topsy is being played by the one and
only Meryl Streep but that doesn't
change the fact that cousin Topsy
doesn't laugh she might be eccentric but
laughing superpowers just isn't one of
her things instead as her name suggests
she has an upside down shop and she
gives the kids a tour so while kids
today might be in a total all of this
upside-down world
they'll never really experience the true
magic of laughing let's be honest there
was just something special about seeing
Uncle Albert laughing with kids joining
them as they started cackling themselves
and then of course the original Mary
Poppins thought it wasn't funny at all
and brought them all down all while
criticizing the type of ways people
laugh seriously it's a must-see jumping
into a painting one of the most magical
Mary Poppins experiences we've had when
watching the original movie was the fact
that everyone jumped into a painting and
entered a cartoon world seriously
how cool is that Bert's who we'll get to
in just a bit was even cool enough to
paint just the type of picture the kids
wanted to see he even added a road just
so they could believe in the magic more
and then of course came the jumping part
according to Bert Mary Poppins just
jumps into the photo and she enters the
magical world but of course without Mary
Poppins this just isn't possible so Bert
and the kid
actually look like us in real life when
we've tried to do this trick at home
kids today don't get the magic of
painting instead they get the magic of a
china bowl ha guys you just have to
experience how different it is to
actually jump in a painting instead of
course not in real life because this
won't work unless Mary Poppins is
present Bert
Oh Bert where do we even begin with this
wonderful man the wounds still haven't
healed after we first heard that Bert
won't be in the new Mary Poppins movie
what's magical about Bert you ask
everything every time Bert appears you
know he has something up his sleeve and
he usually comes with a musical number
which makes the entire thing so much
better and of course the adventure is
even bigger when Mary Poppins is
involved Bert was basically able to make
light of every situation the talented
man might not have been able to hold
down a job but this meant he could
become pretty much anything he even
saved the bank's children after they
were being chased by the bankers who
wanted their money he's a class a good
guy but the new movie doesn't even have
a Bert at all it has Jack who was a
Lamplighter and although Jack is played
by lin-manuel Miranda who puts his own
spin on the role he's no happy-go-lucky
Bert who's had hundreds of jobs in the
movie honestly if you want to experience
the Verte magic you'll have to see the
original movie and we promise you won't
have a single ounce of regrets Michael
and Jane banks Michael and Jane banks
might not be magical in their true sense
of the word but their childlike Wonder
definitely is it's just not the same to
see them all grown up the magic gets
kind of lost instead you just have to
experience Michael and Jana's kids and
their attempts to understand at the Mary
Poppins world they don't question
anything they just go along because they
know that their nanny will take them on
the best adventures ever plus they're
absolutely adorable you just need to
hear the song where they sing their
nanny add it to their parents
it's so cute these two definitely put
the magic in the original Mary Poppins
in their own way and going on adventures
with their nanny made us feel like we
were there one of the most amazing
scenes comes from Michael and Jane
singing supercalifragilistic
expialidocious a word which is extremely
hard to say for their father it's hard
to believe that these two were actually
real menaces
MARY POPPINS arrived in their lives they
actually outline every bad thing they
did to their nannies in their hilarious
nanny ad but as soon as Mary Poppins
arrives they magically transformed into
good kids good kids who now have their
own kids in the new movie and they're
convinced Mary Poppins was just a
figment of their imagination all this
time the original soundtrack the
original Mary Poppins soundtrack
includes 17 songs and we couldn't pick
our favorites even if we tried songs
like sisters suffer gets the perfect
nanny
supercalifragilistic expialidocious a
spoonful of sugar and many others are a
must here for any disney fan who hasn't
grown up with these toons seriously you
just have to put them on it's the songs
many adults have stuck in their heads to
this day and by the look of it they're
not leaving anytime soon all songs are
catchy and many tracks such as feed the
birds will make you unexpectedly cry the
new soundtrack definitely pays homage to
some of these iconic songs but along
with the change lyrics come changed
titles you'll find 27 songs on the new
soundtrack which is definitely a plus
for those who just can't get enough of
the Mary Poppins music but still it's
just not the same guys while the new
soundtrack comes with plenty of
spectacular musical numbers that are
just as athletic as they are
choreographed the old school scenes just
seem a bit less intense and almost
spontaneous but we're glad kids today
can still experience the magic of
jumping in a painting or should we say a
cracked china bowl it's still sort of
the same right at least there's that
have you seen the original Mary Poppins
yet do you prefer the old version or the
new version come let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more fuel good content thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]